FOR QUITE A WHILE.
THE FIRST CAREER HAT TRICK, 366
NHL GAME, THE GUY SIGNED TO A
HEFTY CONTRACT.
BUT NOW, WE'VE GOT WARD BEING --
OR I SHOULD SAY, ANOTHER RUN AT
SIMMONDS, AND SIMMONDS WILL DROP
THE GLOVE, AS RUSSELL REQUEST
REALLY THROW.
AND NOW RAY EMERY IS RACING THE
LENGTH OF THE ICE.
RAY EMERY IS CHALLENGING HOLTBY,
SAYING, NO, I DON'T THINK I WANT
TO GO.
AND THE REFEREE WILL TRY TO KEEP
THAT SEPARATED.
AND HE WON'T BE ABLE TO DO THAT
AS AWAY THEY GO.
EMERY WITH THE RIGHT HAND,
HAMMERING AWAY ON HOLTBY.
>> CAPITALS NOT COMING TO HIS
AID AT THIS POINT, AS EMERY IS
JUST HAVING HIS WAY WITH HOLTBY.
>> WELL, THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON,
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF GOING
BACK-AND-FORTH, AND ANYTHING BUT
FRIENDLY.
>> AND ANOTHER ONE GOING NOW, AS
LECAVALIER IS TRADING WITH
ALEXI, AND NOW SCHENN GOING AT
IT, AS WELL, WITH URBOM, AND
IT'S A LINE BRAWL FOR WELL HERE
AT WELLS FARGO CENTER.
JUST ABOUT EVERYBODY TANGLED UP
RIGHT HERE.
SCHENN GOES DOWN AS URBOM LINES
UP ON TOP OF THAT SCUFFLE.
A LOT OF FRUSTRATION.
>> THIS IS FRUSTRATION.
ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS THE CALLING CARD.
THIS IS SAYING, OKAY, GUY, WE'RE
GETTING WAXED NOW IN THE SCORE.
BUT, HEY, DON'T LEAVE ANYTHING
ON THE ICE.
GO HOME AND UNDERSTAND YOU'LL